so i'd like to imagine the cake are you
imagining a cake
good uh better still let's use a cake
shall we look and i've even got a sign
for you
two candles and one cake so that is that
is the new puzzle the puzzle was
originally set without a cake it was a
stick i've deliberately got a linear
cake we have two candles i like your
choice of candles these are fresh
candles unlit and they're both blue that
might be important later on that we
can't tell the difference although a
spoiler alert it's not gonna be that
important and the puzzle is very simple
brady i would like you to imagine that
the candles are placed randomly on the
cake there should be a klaxon going off
like what do what do i mean by random
but i will tell you i mean uniformly
randomly on a line along this cake i
don't care about the sideways movement
like imagine there's a line along the
center the candles go in somewhere if i
wanted to do it simulate it maybe i
could generate a random number from zero
to one
in some uniform way and use that to mark
how far out so maybe that one goes there
and this one goes somewhere else
randomly there the puzzle now comes when
you pick up a knife and you say
the cut of this cake we're going to
split it into two portions happens also
randomly if i cut it here then i'm not
too worried about the unequal pieces
we'll just deal with the aftermath of
that another day
the point i want to talk about this time
is that there is not a candle on each
piece
so the question becomes now a
probability question
if the candles go on randomly and the
cut is done randomly what are the
chances that each piece has a
candle i'm interested to ask your
intuition brady what is the probability
of
each piece having a candle feels like
it's going to be 50 50. why
i know i'm asking you why why you're
operating your camera and that's always
tough but
it feels like the cut should be 50 50.
what about the cut it feels like when
you average out where all the cuts
happened after a zillion cuts
the average is in the middle the average
is in the middle i agree and actually
that's true of the candles too yeah but
that makes it slightly less intuitive
because they're all averaging to the
same place now so
the thing i like about this puzzle is
that at first glance to me and i'm a
mathematician but i'm not you know i'm
not an eight-grade mathematician i'm a
maths teacher really it feels to me at
first glance i don't know how to start i
don't know how to start putting numbers
on this other than my intuition
um a lot of people say 50 to me they
think that's so your intuition is like
other people's can i ask a question yeah
is it possible to cut the candle i'm
assuming it's impossible to cut the can
i think that's a good assumption and i
love working with you brady you're an
excellent mathematical modeler you are
aware of the complications that could
get involved and you decide to make
things simple now we once we solve this
one we could start having non non
infinitely small point candles and do it
but i suggest we don't bother yet this
is what mathematical modelling is all
right let's keep it simple until we've
sorted the simple one out that's the
puzzle if you haven't already paused the
video and you want to think about it
now's a good time what i'd like to do
for this one is solve it in
more than one way and that's kind of the
point i wanted to talk about here is
that mathematicians
solve things in more than one way and
that's almost always what makes
some profound insight occur because if
you say it from one perspective and
another perspective you've got like a
joining up at the back and that's a nice
moment so we're going to try that in
this one other piece of problem-solving
advice and for you as well that if
you're stuck on something try a simpler
puzzle
so if i took one of the candles away
my question has now no meaning right
well the chances we get a candle on each
piece obviously
can't happen so counter goes on and i
cut somewhere randomly one of the
chances is on the left
the candle 50 50. that it's got to be 50
50. it feels like there's symmetry all
over the place they're both random and
actually the easy way to answer that i
think is an ordering idea either the
candle comes first or the cut comes
first and there's no reason why one
should be more than the other so you've
got to go 50 50.
that gives us a clue for our first way
of solving the problem hey if we want to
split this into
three ways to solve this problem here's
part one ordering
so ordering solved the simpler version
it was either the candle first or the
cut first
so why don't we try some ordering
argument and this is where i probably
have to write some things down c for
candle yeah do i do i differentiate
between the two candles this is the
other problem mathematicians have is
like do i need to model them as
different and we've got two candles that
look identical so i'm just going to say
they're indistinguishable so let's say
the candle could come first and then the
other candle and then the cut that would
be one way of ordering the outcome what
are you going to call a cut
we could use like a v shaper cut or a k
k for knife yeah
i mean it's annoying it's an annoying uh
initial letter to use frankie i like k
for knife because k as a strike in
baseball as well so that is one
possibility i think this is where your
instincts from the simpler one kick in
you realize well there are other
possibilities and they don't feel like
there should be any more likely or less
likely because this is these are all
random candle candle cut
cut with a k is now going to be in my
head forever more what else could happen
brady and this is where i'm at you could
do the knife and then the two candles
yeah and that doesn't feel like less
likely or more likely is there another
option yeah you could do a candle a
knife and a candle and that's the one
that sort of answers the question i
started with is that's the only time
we're going to get a candle on each
piece and since all of these are equally
likely although i haven't done a strong
sort of careful argument for that but it
feels like it's believable that one
should be not more likely than the
others which means that we get a third
for that a third for that and a third
for that i now think this is one way of
claiming that the answer to what are the
chances we get
a candle on each piece
is a third
which isn't a million miles from your 50
but what i like quite a way well i'm
trying to be kind
the intuition for the single candle one
however stupid a question it is it feels
like a dumb question but it's much more
strong intuition for me that that's 50
and then when you can upgrade to you
feel like well maybe it's less likely
and so if i'd given you the chance i'm
sure you'd come down anyway
maybe that's right maybe it's not
there's another way to solve this which
uh
maybe feels a bit more mathematical
but the key to this one is that each of
those options was equally likely
otherwise you can't make an argument i
guess we should mention
that there's a danger in every
probability question about this like
what's the chance you win the lottery
one argument says
you either win or you don't
so it's 50 50 right
and obviously the misconception there is
they're not equally likely so whenever
you're making an argument about
probability from
studying cases you've got to check
they're equally likely which i think
and that would have been the same if we
numbered the candles we had candle one
and candle two i've forgotten about that
and you should you're right to pick me
up on that i'm glad you are so let's say
it's candle one candle two
cut or knife whatever you call it
now we've gotta we've got more options
so maybe if i mark these right that's a
one
and that's these are the best numbers
you've ever seen almost as good as my
mice from a long time ago now there's
another option right with the cut over
there i could have candle two and
counter one and these would switch round
and that would be a different option but
by a similar argument you might see
where this is going there's no reason to
say that one's more likely than the
other and so actually the other option
you said cut to candle candle could be
these two and you can see how this is
going to pan out and now we've got six
options each of which is equally likely
and two of them satisfy our conditions
so i still think we're in a third and
it's nice to know that if you're worried
about whether the candles matter i know
some of you are worried
the uh it doesn't the argument works
both ways around hey that's already two
ways and that was only part one
method two let's do another way of
solving it because if it comes up with
the same answer we're golden if it
doesn't we've got to ask questions about
at least one of the methods so method
two uh i want to go mathematical on this
i said that these are three decisions
there's a candle candle and a cut
let's represent each one of those
random things by a number so counter one
is a number between zero and one uniform
random distribution candle two is a
number zero and one and the cut is a
random number between zero and one which
tells me where it will land now if you
have two numbers you could draw a two
dimensional picture of what could like
you could have one dimension in the
other dimension for the other number
so if you have three numbers like in our
case we need to draw a three-dimensional
picture of the outcome so actually what
i'm talking about is a possibility space
but it's going to be a three-dimensional
picture if i start drawing it on here
being able to draw in 3d is a
surprisingly useful skill for a
mathematician and i'm not doing a
geometry problem here but i'm drawing a
probability space so that's x y and z
z if you're in england and let's say x
is the is candle one y is candle two and
let's say z be the knife somewhere
between zero and one on this axis
somewhere between zero and one on this
axis and some between zero and that will
describe the situation we end up so what
we've actually got is a cube and any
arrangement we've got here is a point
within the cube i mean i can hold one
right so a point in this cube represents
the outcome of our randomness and we can
simulate this nicely on jojoba of course
of course i really like jojoba as a sort
of tool for tinkering and what i did
here was i drew my cake and i've got a
line that i can cut so i can choose
where the cut goes i can choose where
candle one goes and i choose where
candle two goes and you can see that
over on the right it's moving things
around so actually let's let's make this
spin a bit so we can see what's going on
the x-axis for counter one the y-axis of
candle two and the vertical axis for the
knife and all three measurements give
you where the point is in space if i put
the cut somewhere in the middle and the
candle over on the left here can you see
that
this point i'm representing in the 3d
space
is it's gone bold and i've got a little
announcement here saying cut is between
candles you can see that from the cake
but if i put the other candle
over here it hasn't gone bold so
basically there's a whole region of the
cube where we've got a success and
there's a reason the cube where we
haven't got a success so i'm just going
to color in in the cube the points where
the cut is between the candles and i
think you might be able to see where
this is going in terms of get a
probability out of it
because the entire space is all the
possibles
and those two regions it's necessary to
spin this to see what those regions look
like you can imagine that those are the
regions where the knife is in between
and it's really narrow in the middle if
the candles are close together there's
not a big region and it's wide and the
candles are far apart
so the only question now is what volume
of the cube is shaded what proportion
it's not trivial but it's also not that
difficult particularly if i
uh spin one of these regions without
turning i promise you i'm not
transforming i'm just going to spin it
around
and we get a square base pyramid in fact
that's occupying one side of the cube
and going to a point in fact here's a
cube right and if i pull one of these
off
this is the shape we've just made now
the way i've configured it it didn't
automatically turn into this shape but
it is that volume and i i don't know if
you remember the volume of a pyramid
brady there's no reason why you should
so the base times height base times
height gives you the
uh
volume of a cube
and then what do your third it is a
third yeah and this cube was volume one
so this volume is a third
which is a relief because that's the
number we got earlier
and what we've done is we've proved this
in two different ways we've done it by
an ordering argument from our paper
earlier
and ordering in space not time and we've
done it by a geometry argument which is
the volume of a
cube now the one catch is
what if you didn't know the volume of a
pyramid
and so here's my point about solving
things in two ways what i like about
this by accident is that we're solving a
probability problem we did it with
ordering we deal with geometry and if i
don't know what the volume of a square
based pyramid is
i can prove it to you by probability i'm
saying the answer is a third so the
volume of this shape is in fact the
third of a cube and hey a proof of the
volume of a square based pyramid via a
cake cutting exercise
this is a serious point if you can solve
things in more than one way you have two
perspectives and there's quite often a
moment of profound insight like that's
when mathematicians get excited you have
two different ways of looking at a
problem worth mentioning there's another
way of proving these fit together to
make a full thing and there's three of
them if i lock them together these are
3d printed then
they obviously make a cube now that's
not a mathematical proof but it's pretty
hard to argue that those three shapes do
make a cube and therefore if they're
identical they are third each so we've
done the two different ways but i
promise there was deep water here maybe
this isn't so deep it's a profound
moment to do things from two ways but
there's at least another way of doing
this and a glimpse of why questions like
this are maybe more dangerous than you
want them to be i'm gonna refer to
something which you talked about with
grant in a recent video about bertrand's
paradox and how thinking about cake led
me on to thinking a lot about what you
and grant talked about so the third way
of solving this and this is a nice thing
for all mathematical problems is instead
of theorizing just do it
so uh you're gonna record a thousand
takes of me just no no we're not gonna
do it the trouble is this is where you
start noticing how would you actually
pick a random point for the candle
without like a random number generator
it's a pain so
without cutting the cake and spoiling
our tea break later we'll simulate it uh
what mathematicians might call a monte
carlo method but we'll simulate it
because if it doesn't give us a third we
start to doubt all the theory which
we've carefully proven twice so let's
simulate it so apologies for the crudity
of this model i feel like i'm quitting
doc brown there um but this one's not a
scale model of hill valley this is a
scale model of a rubbishy rectangular
cake i've got two tiny candles on here
and a cut and all it's going to do if i
click on one of the buttons here it's
just going to pick random positions for
each of them and you can see this one
there's a cut just in between the
candles success and it's going to count
them and i'm not going to keep clicking
i'm just going to let it go this isn't
rigged but it's done 50 odd trials now
it's not doing super quickly but we've
got a success rate ticking away up here
that is relievingly to me as a
mathematician settling around about a
third now i wouldn't expect it to be
really tight on a third until i've done
thousands and it actually always
surprises me when i do models how long
it takes to converge on what theories
even if i believe the theory it takes a
long time for randomness to to back it
up but it's not bad i mean this feels
like i have rigged it but it's settling
about 0.34 but this is backing us up
which is a relief so the two ways of
solving it don't feel like they've had
any crisis of conscience and the
experiment however
computer remodeled it is is is backing
us up slightly above a third at the
moment the trouble is when we upgraded
this problem from sticks to cake it
feels very natural for me to then in my
head upgrade from
linear cake to a proper cake
so i started asking the question what
happens if you do this on a square cake
or a round cake which feels much more
traditional and
i scared myself slightly
if you'd like to see ben scaring himself
with a proper cake check out the links
to part two of this video they'll be on
the screen and in the description
or if you'd like to just see more number
five videos about stuff getting cut well
let's just say that's a topic we've
covered before cutting a round cake on
scientific principles i mean there's
more to a cake than just size some
people like the sort of crusty bit
around the outside
again links in all the usual places
[Music]